okay I want to say something about my
friend Jimmy Kimmel who I am very proud
of because he brought this issue into
American living rooms in a way it
wouldn't have done before and Jimmy I'm
glad your baby's getting to be okay and
and I'm and I'm flattered you're named
it after me but here's the thing Jimmy
said if your baby's going to die and it
doesn't have to it shouldn't matter how
much money you make I think that's
something whether you're a Republican or
a Democrat we all agree on and
unfortunately that's not true right and
that needs to be said that's not true
one side wants to tax rich people so
babies don't have to die and one side is
mostly against that and this lets
Republicans off the hook let's not
around with this we are not on the same
page with this this is not a squabble
now where it's about child whose sides
being is about values I mean what we've
seen this is a clarifying week because
what this vote showed was a kind of
willingness to embrace naked cruelty
people will die people will die and they
know it and it's a price they're willing
to pay we are not all on the same page
we don't all agree we are not all on the
same page we do not all agree but I
think one of the things we have to
remember is 20 Republicans voted against
the spill and the truth is we also know
running out of yet but we also know that
it was actually the strategy of the
House Republicans who are trying to nip
this deal together frankly to get the
freedom caucus once again thanks to
gerrymandering they have undue influence
in Congress outside of the percentage of
popular vote in the states they're
representing so they're not actually
reflecting a lot of their constituents
and that's what we have to remember
particularly as we're thinking about how
we go into the 28 yeah I mean I don't
know if Jimmy Kimmel's moving monologue
will change people's minds about this
but I think it already has but I also
think losing your health insurance might
change one's mind about this yes being
unable to have your kids covered when
they're in an emergency like camp
but the problem with that with saying
that is is I know he's not a political
guy especially is that that's what makes
people not vote they think well they're
all the same it's just a petty squabble
you know what we need we need uh some
kind of outside dealmaker who'd come in
and shake things up yeah and and let me
give you Joe Walsh's he's our next
congressman a Republican who entered
Jimmy he said sorry Jimmy your sad story
doesn't obligate me or anybody else to
pay for somebody else's health care and
that is their view that is a product not
a right and in fact health care is a
stick to stimulate you to do better so
you can buy your own health care this is
same thing with Donald Trump about why
couldn't we have solved the Civil War
because one side thought that black
people were farm equipment that could
sing well it's actually many of the
states of the Confederacy that refused
to expand Medicaid under Obama care
right yes but what I would say about
your point bill which I again I think we
have to remember it's not just Jimmy
Kimmel I mean Ben Jackson for those who
may have seen senator Marquis had a
constituent who actually posted his own
video in his daughter's hospital room
she's in a hospital bed he said he's
been sitting there for 101 days and that
if this goes through the Senate that
he's going to watch his daughter die so
the reality here is that it's not just
Jimmy Kimmel with Jimmy Kimmel did is
give a much bigger platform you're the
voice of a whole bunch of people who
have all them so here so glad he did I
don't buy it
look we're violating what we just
witnessed in an election Jimmy Kimmel
whether we like or do not represent at
least elites on the east and west coast
who voted for Hillary Clinton
they had years to determine whether they
liked Obama they didn't they voted for
somebody else and there's a huge
quantity of red states that said screw
you so we look at this and hope that
this man represents the the undercurrent
in America that wants change and the
answer is they wanted change in a
different direction they voted for it so
we don't have to like it that's just
wrong yet I may be wrong but voters no
Trump ramas coverage for everyone and
got elected on that basis I think that
people start losing it
it's not going to be good that's right
this is inconsistent with his campaign
pledges as many of his positions are and
secondly even when you look at what
happened in the election he really won
this election by 80,000 votes you mean
this notion that there was first of all
almost 3 million popular votes for
Hillary Clinton group but secondly it
really came down to three states
Wisconsin Michigan and Pennsylvania the
grand total was about 80,000 that
delivered the unfortunate electoral
college to him so that is not quite the
landslide that it was reported